MURDER TWO BUT NOT BE MEDITATED
MURDER.
I’M DELIGHTED THAT THE THREE --
>> Sean: GERALDO, LET ME
INTERRUPT YOU, IF I MAY
BRYAN LLENAS IS ONE OF THE LEAD
POLICE OFFICERS.
HE’S BEEN THERE WITH THESE
PEOPLE AND THEY HAVE BEEN
PEACEFUL TONIGHT.
THEY ARE GETTING ON THEIR KNEES,
COOPERATING AND GETTING ARRESTED
AS THIS PERFUME HAS BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR SOME TIME.
BUT BRYAN LLENAS IS ON THE SCENE
AND TALKING WITH THE LEAD POLICE
OFFICERS, BRYAN.
>> SEAN, TALK TO ME ABOUT WHAT
JUST HAPPENED AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE ARRESTED AND WHY
WERE THEY ARRESTED.
>> WE HAVE BEEN WALKING AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME, IN THE STREETS,
AND AT 8:00, THAT IS THE CURFEW.
THIS IS THE AREA THAT WE’VE HAD
THEM IN THE LAST TWO NIGHTS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS
HERE.
WE GAVE THEM WARNINGS.
CURFEW WAS IN EFFECT.
NO ONE WANTED TO LEAVE SO WE
BROUGHT OUR TEAMS AND I MADE 60
ARRESTS AND ABLE TO DISPERSE THE
REST OF THE CROWD.
>> CAN YOU TALK TO ME A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT IS IT THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE BEEN FACING FROM
LOOTERS?
>> FROM DAY ONE, THURSDAY NIGHT,
ROCKS, BOTTLES, BRICKS, WE’VE
BEEN SHOT AT, RUN OVER BY CARS,
BUT THEY ARE STILL OUT THERE AS
YOU CAN SEE IN FORCE KEEPING THE
CITY SAFE AND BEING EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE, DOING THE JOB TO MAKE
SURE THIS CITY IS OUR CITY.
WE ARE ONE WITH THE PROTESTERS.
WE ARE OUT THERE FOR A JUSTIFIED
CAUSE, BUT NOT FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO CAUSE MAYHEM FOR
THE CITY.
>> THE NYPD HASN’T DONE ITS JOB
AND HASN’T DONE ENOUGH.
CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT YOUR
RESPONSES TO THAT.
>> I DON’T WANT TO GO BACK AND
FORTH WITH THE GOVERNOR.
THE GOVERNOR IS THE GOVERNOR.
FOR ALL I KNOW THERE ARE MEN AND
WOMEN EVERY DAY AS YOU SAW HERE,
WE ARE MOVING TACTICALLY AND WE
TAKE PEOPLE OUT.
WE ALLOW PEOPLE TO PROTEST, BUT
IF THEY START VIOLATING THE LAW,
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE ACTION.
AND WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE CITY UNDER CONTROL.